The thin, pale humanoid anomaly had just found
itself… in Minecraft, of all places.
The all too familiar wail of emergency alarms
rang out through the corridors of the Foundation
facility.
It had happened again, another containment
breach.
Of course, the on-site personnel were more
than familiar with the protocols for a situation
like this, so well-versed in what to do during
an emergency that it had become second nature.
Whether they were research staff evacuating
for their own safety, or security teams moving
in to recapture the escaped anomaly and get
the situation under control, everyone was
moving like they had been programmed, muscle
memory taking over.
The loose anomaly was none other than SCP-096,
all Foundation personnel were alerted and
reminded not to look directly at the creature.
There was just one problem: they couldn’t
look even if they’d ignored their order
to try.
Nobody could… because the Shy Guy was nowhere
to be found.
Well, nowhere in the real world, at least.
This whole situation – bizarre even by the
Foundation’s standards – had all started
with an experiment involving a member of the
disposable D Class Personnel.
Yet another dangerous convict severing one
of several life sentences, now being used
as an expendable human lab rat for the Foundation’s
often sinister purposes.
The experiment in question was an attempt
to further test the limitations of SCP-096’s
abilities.
By now, the Foundation had done extensive
research into the creature known as the Shy
Guy.
They knew its particular brand of anomalous
qualities were triggered when anyone looked
directly at it.
Being observed would instantaneously send
SCP-096 into an uncontrollable rage state,
causing it to pursue its observer until they
were no longer standing.
SCP-096 was known to be able to travel at
speeds so relentless it was pretty much possible
to stop.
One moment it was sobbing and screeching in
its cell having just been observed, and minutes
later, the wide-jawed, long-limbed monster
was standing behind whoever had seen it, making
its screaming face the image its victim took
to the grave with them.
Foundation researchers knew that SCP-096’s
rage state could be triggered by as little
as someone seeing the slightest hint of a
creature.
Even if the Shy Guy had been captured as a
tiny speck in the background of a photograph,
it would come after anyone whose eyes so much
as glanced over that speck.
It also didn’t matter how far away the observer
was – SCP-096 couldn’t be outrun, it could
track down anyone wherever they were in the
world.
But what if a person who had observed the
Shy Guy was no longer in the world…
The experiment had taken a lot of trial and
error – after all, digitizing a human being
and transforming their entire consciousness
into code was no easy task.
But the Foundation wasn’t above breaking
more than a few eggs to make an omelette,
especially when those eggs were the brains
of a few D Class Personnel.
Actually, the first test subjects turned out
more scrambled or fried, certainly overdone,
given the amount of smoke coming from their
ears.
But eventually, the research team had perfected
the device they had dubbed the ‘Neural Harness’,
a headset that could translate a person’s
mind into pure digital code.
Their consciousness would be extracted from
their body, leaving their physical form an
empty shell while a digital copy of them was
able to traverse the local on-site computer
network.
Of course, the Foundation wasn’t about to
let a digitized D Class run amok with their
systems, so their coding experts wrote a number
of specialized parameters into their successful
test subject.
Now, the digital D Class could be programmed
to follow the Foundation’s directive.
From his perspective, it was like he was floating
through cyberspace, towards the system the
Foundation had directed him too: a surveillance
camera inside SCP-096’s cell that usually
remained inactive.
But not today.
The camera blinked to life as soon as the
D Class’s code-based consciousness reached
it, and through it, he was able to observe
SCP-096, sitting against the far wall of its
containment chamber, gently whimpering and
rocking back and forth.
That is, until the creature felt that familiar
sensation of being watched.
It stood up, enraged, wailing uncontrollably
as the D Class watched from within the camera.
Then, a split second later, SCP-096 appeared
to blink out of existence.
It hadn’t worked, the experiment had failed,
and the digital D Class began to panic.
Before the Foundation’s coders could stop
him, he frantically scoured the local network
for anything, some kind of escape route back
into the real world.
Maybe, he thought, if he could get back into
his body, it wouldn’t count?
Technically, his digital self was separate
from his physical form, so he might get out
of SCP-096’s clutches on a technicality.
But it was impossible, his body was already
burned out by the Neural Harness, there was
no way for the D Class to transfer himself
back.
There was only one option left: hide.
And, as it turned out, someone had forgotten
to uninstall a certain building game from
a computer in one of the Foundation doctor’s
offices.
The D Class’s digitized mind zapped him
into Minecraft; from his point of view, it
was just like he existed within the game itself.
He did a computerized equivalent of breathing
a sigh of relief, only to take back all those
ones and zeros in a horrified gasp as he noticed
a tall, wiry-framed figure before him.
It hadn’t worked, SCP-096 had still managed
to follow him into Minecraft.
Even in a world of computer code, the Shy
Guy was able to dispatch its digital observer
quite easily, and what had once been a living
human mind in the form of binary code was
quickly deleted.
But that’s when SCP-096 started to take
notice of its surroundings.
With the most recent person to see it gone,
it had a chance to actually take in where
it was.
The bright rays of warm light coming down
from a cube-shaped sun reveal a welcoming
landscape all around, constructed entirely
from cubes.
It fascinated SCP-096, instilling a kind of
childlike wonder in the Shy Guy the likes
of which it hadn’t experienced since…
well, since it couldn’t remember when.
Rather than leaving, instantly reappearing
in its containment chamber, SCP-096 made the
conscious decision to start exploring.
There was a mountainous biome surrounding
SCP-096, stony spires reaching up towards
a clear sky, with a waterfall cascading its
way down the nearest of them.
At the foot of one of the mountains was the
opening to a cave, which the Shy Guy found
itself wandering towards.
The light from the sun, while a pleasant and
welcome change to the surroundings it was
used to, was a little harsh on SCP-096’s
sunken eyes.
So, instead it began to gravitate towards
the shadowy confines of the caves, not unlike
the usual darkness of its containment chamber
back at the Foundation.
Traversing through long, winding corridors
of stone, SCP-096 found itself having to bend
down, to avoid hitting its head on the cave’s
low ceiling – obviously, this formation
of rocky blocks hadn’t formed with someone
of the Shy Guy’s height in mind.
There was a low, warm glow coming from the
farthest side of the tunnel, and the thin
creature made its way closer and closer, despite
the stone walls around it feeling like a tighter
confinement than its cell.
Approaching the source of the light, SCP-096
was relieved that the cave opened out into
a more spacious area, the cramped tunnel giving
way to an expansive chamber that lay within
the heart of the mountain.
The warm, orangey glow had been coming from
a flowing stream of boiling hot lava, that
seemed to trickle down from somewhere above,
creating a deadly, fiery pool directly in
the Shy Guy’s path.
But just before it could turn back and leave
the cave through the way he came, SCP-096
sensed that familiar feeling of something
observing him.
Across the lava pool, on the other side, was
a creature comprised of a green cube for a
head, with a long, armless cuboid body, and
four cubed feet.
If it had been present in the real world,
it might have been made out of leaves, like
a living shrub.
It was staring directly at the Shy Guy from
across the lava, only for this strange newcomer
to disappear a moment later.
The Creeper hissed, before it realized that
SCP-096 had leaped up behind it to land a
fatal blow.
But little did the infamously anxious anomaly
realize the sentient shrub wasn’t done.
There was a colossal boom that caused SCP-096
to stagger backwards, whimpering at the sudden
loud explosion and the pain that had accompanied
it.
The Creeper had blown itself to pieces, but
in doing so, had left a lasting injury, that
caused SCP-096 considerable discomfort as
it began limping towards the cave that led
out the opposite side of the mountain.
Despite its injury, the Shy Guy was still
able to move with relative ease, and the further
it went, the more it seemed to gradually heal.
However, it was as it stepped out once more
into the sunlight that the creature realized
just how hungry it was.
Back in the real world, it hadn’t eaten
for several hours, and surprisingly – even
while accidentally stuck in digitized form
– the hunger mechanics of Minecraft were
having an effect on SCP-096.
The Shy Guy started searching around for anything
that could prove to satiate its hunger.
There was a grove of trees not far, so SCP-096
lumbered closer to take a closer look.
It couldn’t be certain, but it felt there
was at least a slim chance that there were
apples growing among the leaves.
But even at the anomaly’s own elongated
height, it couldn’t simply reach up to pick
them.
However, it was while swiping its arms up
at the tree that the Shy Guy swung its fist
and knocked the tree trunk.
To the creature’s surprise, it was able
to chip away at the wood with its hands, punching
at the tree until the trunk had been reduced
to a collection of wooden blocks that the
Shy Guy was able to collect.
And sure enough, some red apples dropped from
the leaves above, enough to quell the hunger
that SCP-096 was feeling, at least for the
time being.
Nearby, something was moving through the trees.
It was yet to lock eyes on SCP-096, but the
second it did, the mob would surely have sealed
its own fate.
As it moved around, minding its own business,
the tall figure overheard the sounds of the
Shy Guy eating, and its attention was drawn
to where the creature was standing, enjoying
an apple.
Sensing it had been seen, SCP-096 turned and
locked eyes with the entity.
It was perhaps the only other being in Minecraft
that was a similar height and stature to the
anomaly itself – in fact, the pair were
strikingly similar.
Before SCP-096 could carry out its usual method
of attack, the Enderman suddenly teleported
out of view.
But it was too late now, both it and the Shy
Guy had looked at the other’s face; both
had been provoked, and were compelled to react
in exactly the same way.
Just as SCP-096 entered its rage state, the
Enderman too opened its mouth and began to
shake, making loud, lengthy sounds not dissimilar
to the Shy Guy’s own angered screams.
But something profoundly strange happened
next.
SCP-096 and the Enderman kept attempting to
pursue one another, appearing in a new location
within the Minecraft world, neither one getting
close enough to the other.
They’d teleport, only for the other to teleport
away the moment they saw each other, each
trying to catch one another but always staying
one step ahead or behind.
This rapid chase almost became a strange,
ongoing sort of teleporting dance between
SCP-096 and the Enderman.
At first, the Shy Guy had been compelled to
attack the Enderman, like it was with any
who looked directly at it.
But as they appeared and disappeared from
place to place, the creature started to feel
an odd kinship with this shadowy fellow.
It was so used to being frightened and alone,
to its overwhelming feelings of insecurity
and self-loathing, that the simplicity of
just traversing the open world – with a
creature very alike itself in many ways – it
had all come as a welcome change.
SCP-096 found it therapeutic even, and before
long, was following the Enderman not out of
any intention to do it harm, but just to feel,
for a while, like it had a friend.
Just a little bit longer, SCP-096 thought,
welcoming the enjoyment it felt playing this
game of Minecraft.
Now go and check out “SCP-1471 MALO, BUT
HACKED MINECRAFT” and “SCP MINECRAFT WORLD
DESTROYER SCP-4335 - A WELT IN THE CRUCIBLE”
for more!